les habitants de kiev redoute
l'offensive c'est le cas aussi des
habitants d'odessa ville stratégique
notamment en raison de son port
ouverture de l'ukraine sur le monde
odessa s'est réveillé ce matin donc
également au son des sirènes on retrouve
sur place notre envoyé spécial
gwendoline de bono bourgeon gwendoline
qu'elle semble être la stratégie de la
russie pour cette ville d'odessa
ou alors effectivement on a entendu tout
ce matin les sirènes d'alert sans que
l'on sache forcément pourquoi et c'est
souvent le cas ce que l'on peut regarder
à odessa si le front le plus proche qui
se trouve dans cette ville de nicolas
yves qui est véritablement le le verrou
avant des salles à où les russes
concentrent leurs efforts ça se trouve à
100 km donné ça environ pour l'instant
il n'y a pas de progression de l'armée
russe réellement sur ce front à l'armée
russe n'a pas pour l'instant lancé à
dassault à nous y étions encore hier
toute la journée ce que l'on voit et
c'est beaucoup de tirs d'artillerie et
l'on sent vraiment que l'armée russe et
bien intensifient la pression sur les
civils avant-hier neuf civils ont été
tués dans cette ville de nicolas yves
donc c'est ce qu'on voit c'est cette
stratégie russe sur ce front sud qui est
d'intensifier la pression sur les civils
de frapper des cibles militaires mais
aussi de plus en plus de cibles où se
trouvent des civils pour les pousser à
partir pour pouvoir est bien dans le
même temps se réorganiser et ensuite et
bien lancé une attaque ce que l'on voit
aussi ce sont des mouvements russe qui
vont par le nord 1 au dessus si vous
voulez de cette ville de miku live qui
en fait cette route qui va du sud inde
et ville portuaire de la mer noire
jusqu'à kiev là les russes essaient de
manoeuvrer et il y à des combats hier
nous nous avons passé une partie de la
matinée dans la morgue de micola iv ne
s'est pas passé dix minutes et bien sans
que des décors de soldats ukrainiens
soient amenés donc cela donne une idée
des pertes côté ukrainien qui sont
également nombreuses mais également de
la résistance qu'oppose les combattants
ukrainien aux troupes russes fassent
bonjour gwendoline face à ce rouleau
compresseur russe précisément qu'elle
est là la stratégie qu'elle des forces
d'ukrainiens
alors ce que l'on ce que l'on voit nous
ne sommes pas autorisés à accompagner
sur le front les forces une chrétienne
mais mais ce que l'on voit en
s'approchant en tout cas ce sont des
forces ukrainienne qui sont extrêmement
mobiles extrêmement organisés
extrêmement discipliné c'est c'est assez
impressionnant et qui ont un avantage
considérable qui est tout de même
l'immense support de la population
partout on voit par exemple les
restaurants près du front qui qui
cuisinent pour eux les locaux qui leur
amènent de la nourriture qu'il le ramène
des vivres on sait on nous sommes rendus
dans les villages qui sont au nord de
cette ville de nicolet qui est sur un
axe où les russes essaye de manoeuvrer
là les habitants informe renseigne les
soldats ukrainien donc c'est vrai que
même si les soldats ukrainiens sont
clairement inférieurs en ont eh bien ils
disposent de cet avantage qui est
toujours un avantage très important dans
une bataille qu est le soutien quasi
totale de la population